He is recognized as the greatest athletes of modern times in the boxing ring,
that he was nothing short of superb punishing his opponent so well and it was
outside of the ring that he would have his greatest battles and show the world
what it really meant to be a man.
And this episode of Biographics,
we discovered what it was that made a Mohammad Ali the absolute greatest.
It's just a job.
Grass grows,
birds fly waves pounding the sand.
I'd beat people up.
Cassius Marcellus clay was born on January the 17th of 1942 in Louisville,
Kentucky.
His father,
Cassius Sr was it east sign paints out while his mother Adesa worked as a maid
for a wealthy White Family in Louisville are precocious but polite child.
Young Cassius was raised as a god fearing baptist along with his younger
brother,
Rudy and his younger years.
He gave no indication to his athletic future.
He steered clear of sports,
preferring to play marbles with Rudy Ball,
read comic books on his bed in 1954 when he was 12 years old,
Casios and a friend rode their bicycles to the Columbia Auditorium,
which was hosting the Louisville home show.
They spent the afternoon checking out the wares of various African American
merchants and gorging themselves on the Free Popcorn and candy that was on offer
when they emerge from the exhibition.
The boys were dismayed to discover the Cassius as brands new red and white.
A Schwinn bike was missing the why.
Well,
it had been stolen.
Cassius was absolutely livid with rage drawing an upset.
He began asking people if they'd seen who took his bike.
A woman suggested that he reported the theft to officer Joe Martin who operated
a boxing gym in a nearby basement finding.
Martin Cassius explained to what has happened.
I think that he was going to wobble whoever had taken his bike,
Marta,
and it had been teaching boxing for decades,
asked if the boy knew how to fight.
When Cassius admitted this,
he didn't.
The officers suggested that maybe he has a learn.
Well this,
this was the beginning of a long friendship and to Glorious Korea,
Huh?
Cassius.
He threw himself into boxing training with a passion and commitment that
impressed Martin.
Although we had it very little natural skill,
he had more heart than anyone else in the gym.
It raced to the gym as soon as school let out and would train even on Saturdays.
Martin had simply never seen a kid work quite so hot outside of the gym.
Cassius stayed away from anything that would interfere with his training.
He was displaying the kind of determination and discipline that was lacking in
many of the older boxes that Martin coached Martin.
He introduced Cassius to at local boxing trainer named Fred stoner who helped
teach him the fundamentals of the sport under the guidance of these two men,
young play began winning one man.
What about after another month after month,
year after year,
a handful of amateur winds built up a formidable records.
By the age of 18 he had won 108 bouts,
six Kentucky Golden Glove Championships and two national Aau titles in the ring.
Cassius absolutely fearless.
He carried a self confidence and a belief in his ability that put his opponents
off guard before the first ground bell met even sounds it,
but this was in great contrast to his personal life because there he really
struggles.
It was a poor student with teachers unable to understand why he couldn't
transfer the dedication you put into his sport into his studies.
No one realized at the time that has struggles in school they would do to the
reading disability dyslexia in February of 1957 professional boxer,
but Willie Per Strano visited Louisville with his trainer,
Angelo Dundee Cassius found out where he was staying and phoned for Strano his
hotel room.
If I was picked up by done deep,
Cassius blurted out that he was going to be the world's greatest boxer and that
he wanted to meet for Strano with nothing on their schedule.
That afternoon done the infrastructure actually invited Cassius.
Do you have a hotel room for the next several hours?
Cassius peppered Australia with questions only pausing long enough to predict
his own future.
Greatness of amused Angelo.
Dundee was impressed with the boy ends.
Kept in touch with him.
He's sometimes since Cassius and his family free tickets when one of his boxes
had a fight in lines up in Louisville.
In March,
1959 Cassius was training in a gym in Chicago,
Illinois prior to an Aau talks bout,
yeah,
the hood.
Some other boxes talking about a group called the nation of Islam who were re
spousing black pride back.
I'm in Louisville.
He decided to learn more about the group by doing a school assignment about
them.
However,
his teacher shut the idea down,
telling him that the group was dangerous and that they preached hatred against
all white people.
Play,
however,
was still intrigued by the nation of Islam.
He got ahold of a copy of a newspaper that they put out and started reading as
much as he could about them.
At the same time,
he was wrestling with the weighty decision about what direction to take his
boxing future.
People that have been talking him up as a hot prospect for the 1960 Olympics in
Rome,
but at that time only amateurs are able to compete in the Olympics,
so he had to decide if he was going to town professional or compete in Rome as
part of the United States is boxing team.
It was at this point 30 turned to his friend Angelo Dundee for advice,
don't told Cassius that he could earn more money as a pro if he was an Olympic
champion.
First.
As a result,
he decided to stay in his amateur career runs compete in the Olympics.
Well,
at the time the American Olympic team was set to depart for Italy.
Playing was in peak physical condition and mentally primed for victory,
but there was one slight problem.
He was absolutely terrified at the prospect of flying on a plane.
In fact,
he was so terrified that he always passed up the opportunity to represent his
country.
He,
he finally relented when it's old mentor Joe Martin convinced him to fly.
We think parachute on his back.
Fortunately it Cassius,
it didn't need to operate as parachutes in the plane.
Touched down in room without any incidents.
He started as an employee campaign with a quick two rounds when over Belgium's
Yvonne,
because that wind was followed by another win over the Soviet Union's getting
reduced shat cough.
He was the previous gold medal winner at the 1956 Olympics.
Cassius then triumphed in the semifinals,
defeating Australia's Antony Madigan.
The only person standing between play and Olympic glory was Poland's is a big
new patters as Koski in the contrast of Cassius,
who would only been boxing for six years.
This man was a three time European champion and even at one bronze in the 1956
Olympics.
However,
it was clay who played the more aggressive game,
throwing an avalanche of punches to take the first round lead the Polish champ.
Well,
he was simply unable to recover and at the ends of three rounds,
Cassius claimed the Olympic,
a light heavyweight gold metal gaseous.
He returns to Louisville eight local hero with even the mayor turning out to
receive him.
He was so proud of his victory that he wore his gold medal everywhere.
About a week after his return,
he had a friend's doctor into our restaurant to get out of the rain.
That's when they tried to order a couple of cheeseburgers and milkshakes.
They were told that the restaurants did not serve black people and they were
thrown out.
Cassius clay was an Olympic champion.
Yes,
it was still a second class citizen in his hometown standing on the second
street bridge.
He grabbed his gold medal,
ripped it from his neck and threw it into the Ohio river.
Despite his frustration with the social climates,
Cassius was facing a bright boxing future turning professional.
He was sponsored by a group of local white businessmen who agreed to sponsor
him.
They offered to pay him at $10,000 up front and to cover all of his training
expenses.
In return,
they would take half his earnings for the next six years.
Despite these impressive victories in Rome,
boxing pundits didn't expect a great career for clay.
The consensus was that he had quick footwork,
but not much else.
He spent too much energy.
They said dancing around the ring man's.
When he lands back to protect his face,
he would leave his body exposed.
However,
Cassius relied on his long reach to strike his opponents from a distance gaseous
well.
He wanted to train under Angelo Dundee,
but as sponsors sent him to California to work with a trainer by the name of
Archie Moore.
He made his pro debut in front of his home crowd on October the 29th of 1960 his
opponent was Tonya,
hadn't sacco clay one the fights with a unanimous six round decision.
It was a great start to his pro career,
but to clay.
Wasn't happy with Archie Moore,
his training style,
and he headed to Miami and doest Angelo Dundee to take over as his trainer dumb.
He agrees,
but it meant the Cassius had to live in a very rough neighborhood that was
filled with gangs and drugs and prostitution.
Still,
he took immediately to his new training environments flourishing under the
tutelage of date.
By now,
it became evident that Cassius was an absolutely masterful self promoter.
In fact,
his mouth,
it worked faster than his fists.
He never tired of announcing that he was the greatest,
the prettiest,
and the fastest athlete to ever step into a ring.
But he was soon encouraged to talk himself up even more.
In June of 1961 clay travel to Las Vegas for a boxing match.
While in Vegas,
you went to see a wrestler by the name of Gorgeous George Cassius watched as
George acted outrageously.
He was trash talking his opponent for an upcoming match he talked to endlessly
before band,
even during the match,
the whole crowd,
well that made them read for the other guy.
But after the match,
Cassius met George backstage.
The rest of their explained that is self promotion was designed to get as many
people as possible to pay to come and see someone shut his mouth.
He advised clay to keep sassing his opponents and to always be outrageous.
He also told him to find himself a gimmick that would set himself apart.
Well,
clay,
he soon found his gimmick.
He would predict the round that he would win the match him
well.
November the 15th 1962 Cassius met his former trainer,
Archie Moore in the ring,
but bold claims that he had developed a lip,
a button,
a punch,
do finally silence the Louisville lip as Cassius had come to be known in
response play,
predicted a fourth round knock outs,
bands.
That is precisely how the fight went down.
Cassius,
he was now a 16 when zero loss pro,
he felt he had an under shot at the heavyweight world champion Sonny Liston.
He engaged upon a campaign of taunting list and into taking the challenge.
They began referring to the champ as a big ugly bear once even travel to his
home town of Springfield,
Colorado and banged on his door at three in the morning to call out the champ
clay.
He made absolutely sure the TV cameras were recording every second of this
charade.
Finally listed,
well,
he had had enough and he agreed to take on the upstart.
The heavyweight champ made a prediction of his own and that would be pain.
There was no idle threats.
Listing was a mountain of a man who had a killer punch.
He was considered by many boxing experts to be unbeatable.
Cassius,
he trained hard for this,
the biggest fight of his life,
but he didn't give it his absolute focus.
Both Cassius and his brother,
Rudy,
they were becoming increasingly interested in the nation of Islam.
They started attending meetings and Cassius became enamored with the leader
Elijah Muhammad.
He also took a great liking to the group spokesman,
knock Max.
As the brothers started spending more time at the mosque in Miami,
Malcolm told Cassius to where his nation of Islam membership proudly when the
title find sponsors learned that the challenger was associating with the nation
of Islam.
They threatened to cancel the event unless he disavowed the grip it's played.
He would not abandon his newfound faith.
He was prepared to walk away from boxing to stay true to himself.
Well,
the sponsors,
they ultimately backed down and the fight he did.
Go ahead.
Now listen.
He was used to knocking out opponents,
the early rounds,
but clay,
he was too fast.
It's quick feet,
danced around the ring.
Anz Liston was simply unable to touch him after a grueling six rounds.
Liston,
he refused to come out for the seventh the 22 year old Cassius clay was now the
youngest heavyweight champ in history as razor sharp canon is.
When was it was superseded the very next day when he officially announced that
he was a member of the nation of Islam and that he was changing his name to
Cassius x.
A week later,
that evolved into Muhammad Ali,
the nation of Islam.
They were very unpopular with most of America.
It was predicted this,
if he fought list,
and again,
there wouldn't be anyone rooting for him.
Well,
the two they did meet again on May the 25th 1965 many in the anxious crowds.
They expect it to see Liston win back the title that he had lost Ali and instead
they were stunned to see the former champ again knocked out in the first rounds.
On November the 22nd 1965 Ali successfully defended his title against former
champ,
Floyd Patterson.
Patterson had spoken out against the nation of Islam and refuse to call alley
buying his Muslim name,
Ali.
They didn't pay for this slight mercilessly pounding him while yelling.
Watched my na in 1966 alley defended his title five times four of those defenses
being held outside of the United States.
On February the sixth 1967 he fought it Ernie to realm.
Then Houston,
Texas to rail was enraged dally buying just like Floyd Patterson before him
refusing the call only by his name.
The result was what many believe to be the worst beating ever dished out in a
professional boxing match.
The champion tortured DRL it for the full 15 rounds,
bringing him up just short of a knockout and then backing off only to wallop
them again with the combinations.
Ali won a unanimous points decision.
Yeah,
Holly's next bottle.
Would it pit him against the might of the United States governments?
On April the 28th 1967 he turns up at the Houston Induction Center for the US
armed forces.
When the time came for him to step forward to signify signifying his induction,
Allie didn't move.
He explains that his religious beliefs prevented him from joining the army and
killing people with whom he had no quarrel.
He further stated that he could not in good conscious give support to a war that
he felt was morally wrong.
Within 24 hours,
Sally had been stripped of his heavyweight title as well as his license to box
in every state in the country in an instant.
That title he had worked so hard for was simply gone.
When the u s government took away his passport,
couldn't even box oversees the governments well.
They had effectively taken away his livelihood.
However,
the champ was never going to lie down.
He became an unlikely hero to the millions of young anti war activists around
the nation.
He spoke at the most prestigious universities where he was introduced as the
first national figure with the courage to stand up against the war in Vietnam.
Still,
the late 1960s were lean years fanny.
On August 17th,
1967 he married Belinda Boyd,
but next year they had a child,
Merriam but Ali's name.
It brought him opportunities and he managed to make ends meet.
He did everything from opening a restaurant,
calls Champ Burgers to starring in a musical big time buck white.
As the years passed,
Mohammad continued training and the hope that one day I would get the
opportunity to reclaim his title.
Finally,
towards the end of the 1970s some promoters in Georgia,
which didn't have the boxing commission organized about against Jerry Quarry,
though slower than he had been Helene,
one in a convincing fashion is now.
Well other states they considered to let him fight again.
If he could get another win under his belt,
he might even get a shot at a reigning champion of Joe Fraser.
Does it get up?
Fraser?
I'm Molly has a Festa feet.
Oscar Bonavena the fight almost when the full 15 rounds,
we've Bonavena taking a great deal of punishments,
but he also dish down to a level of abuse that Mohammed had never had to
withstands before.
Sill Molly one in the last round.
Tko the fight of the century,
the first ever between two undefeated heavyweight champs took place on March the
eighth 1971 phrasing Angelina.
It traded blow after blow five years before that he would have easily dodged.
Some are phrases,
punches person.
Now he could only take the hits and fight through the pain and the abuse,
the fight,
they went the distance.
It could have gone either way,
but in the end it was a unanimous decision to Fraser,
Muhammad Ali.
He had suffered his first professional loss still.
He was determined to get back on top.
He followed up is lost by winning 10 fights in a row,
but it is 11th he was stopped by the formidable can.
Norton who broke his jaw,
but Ali,
he came back in a rematch knocking out Norton in the six rounds and ends up
after this.
Well that came the rematch that he was really after he fought Joe Frazier who
had lost his title to George Foreman for the second time on January the 28th
1974 winning in a 12 rounds unanimous decision.
But Ali,
well,
he still did not have his title back to claim it.
He would have to defeat to the new champ.
This was the 24 year old foreman who would so far at one 40 fights and just lost
eight hadn't gone past the second rounds on paper.
It looked like the 32 year old elite did not have a chance.
The fighter took place in consortia Zaia on October the 30th 1974 over the early
rounds.
It appeared as if Ali was out of his depth with form and apparently pounding him
at will.
What are the was actually doing was allowing foreman to punch himself to
exhaustion and the eight rounds at Mommy's,
it came to life and delivered a devastating series of blows.
The put foreman on the canvas the champion had reclaimed is heavyweight title.
A year later,
he faced drew Fraser for the third time and he believed that this was the
hardest fought heavyweights clash of all time rounds after rounds.
The stunned crowd watched in horror as the battered boxes somehow fought beyond
exhaustion and the ends ballet was declared the winner in the 14th rounds.
He was so exhausted that he couldn't even stand up to celebrate.
Yeah,
an aging all the defendant,
his title seven more times before squaring up to an unknown challenger by the
name of Leon Spinks on February the 15th 1978 I'll leave underestimated the
challenger training lightly and it's not taking the fight seriously enough.
That night he lost his title to a man who didn't deserve to be in the ring with
him at his prime.
Eight months later to smoke obvious signs of developing Parkinson's disease,
he avenged the loss to claim an unprecedented third world heavyweight
championship.
Nine months later,
he retired from the ring,
but is time out of the ring would last for less than a year.
On October the 18th 1980 he suffered a crushing defeat at the hands of his
former sparring partner.
30 homes.
A year later,
he was dispatched by a far less impressive Trevor Burdick time.
Well,
it had finally caught up with Mohammed Ali over the next decade,
has Parkinson's disease steadily got worse?
The body that had served him so well was giving up on him still,
he wasn't done yet.
In the late 1980s Mohammed Ali embarked on a new career as a humanitarian
statesmen and its promotion of Tolerance and peace weld,
right?
But at the time he left us on June the third 2016 he was recognized as one of
the great men and certainly the greatest athlete of the 20th century.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do give it a thumbs up below and do not forget to subscribe if you
haven't already for brand new videos just like this every Monday and every
Thursday.
Also check out some of our other videos from the past over there on the right.
You'll probably enjoy these if you enjoy those.
They're all biographies.
They're all of notable people like Muhammad Ali.
We've got loads of others.
Check those ones out on the rice and maybe what some others,
if you've got some time,
and as always,
thank you for watching.
Okay.